how common is it for athletes to
actually miss to test like this well one
hopes that it won't be common for
athletes to miss tests but the way that
the whereabouts program work it's
entirely possible that an athlete could
miss a test after all the athlete
provides their information they provided
three months in advance and and they
continue to update this information
where they sleep where they're training
where they are for 24 hours a day and
and give a guarantee of one hour per day
where they definitely will be available
for testing but the testing officer
could come at any time they could come
outside that one hour so in many
respects the athlete has no idea that
they have missed a test because they may
not have been expecting the tester to
turn up at that particular time so it
can happen and for the majority of
athletes they will explain to the
testing agency what the circumstances
were that led to their missed test and
then of course it's a matter of whether
they've got the evidence to back that up
and they're believed or not and three
strikes like that in a 12-month period
now since January 2015 would mean that
an actual fact the athlete would face a
violation so he's saying that the way
the tested theory is at the moment is
just not fit for purpose well I think
there are some challenges within the
system we know that athletes aren't
entirely comfortable with the amount of
information they have to provide I mean
we are assured that we should be
collecting this information from
athletes if we intend to test them at
least three times in a 12-month period
but I wonder how many athletes are
providing their daily whereabouts and
yet find that they are not tested as
often as a minimum of three times a year
so it is a matter of a little bit of
frustration but it is the tool we have
presently in order to try and
demonstrate that an athlete is not using
prohibited substances so it's a
necessary evil but it's not perfect as a
system